قال وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو ان
تدخل بلاده في سوريا ساعد في انجاز مهمه
جيو سياسيه تتمثل في قطع ما دعاها سلسله
الثورات الملونه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا واشار الى ان روسيا لا تقتل فقط
من دعاهم الارهابيين في سوريا بل تمنعهم
ايضا من الوصول الى
اراضيها
السلام عليكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش
فيما وراءه ما التهديد الذي مثلته للمصالح
الروسيه هذه الثورات الملونه في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا كما سماها شويجو وما
الاهداف الجيوسياسيه التي تسعى موسكو الى
تحقيقها بناء على نتائج تدخلها في
[موسيقى]
سوريا كما يبدو لم ينسى الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وجنرالاته ودبلوماسي ان
شرر ثورات الربيع العربي قد تطاير الى
بلاده في مظاهرات احتجاجيه حاشده على
نتائج الانتخابات التشريعيه اواخر عام
2011 فادخل وزير دفاع سيرجي شويجو الثورات
العربيه في دائره الثورات الملونه التي
شهدتها دول سوفيتيه سابقه مثل اوكرانيا
وجورجيا وقدم دور قوات بلاده في سوريا
نموذجا للسعي لحفظ الاستقرار العالمي
وتوازن القوى الدوليه واخيرا بصفته ورقه
اعتماد لبناء نظام عالمي جديد وصفه وزير
الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف بنظام ما
بعد الغرب تقرير ناصر اي
طاهر رهاب الثورات الملونه ذاك سقم روسي
مزمن او هي سلسله راها الروس سببا في
تغيرات كبيره عرفتها السياسه الدوليه وت
زن القوى في العالم والاقاليم
والان تفاخر روسيا بانها قطعت تلك السلسله
حين بلغت افريقيا والشرق الاوسط وتلك مهمه
جيو سياسيه في مفهوم وزير الدفاع الروسي
اعان عليها التدخل الروسي في سوريا لم
يخفى على احد حينها نهج موسكو عقيده
عسكريه توسعيه جديده لها اهداف طويله
الامد اقتضى ذلك الحفاظ على وجود دائم
لاساطير في المحيط الاطلسي البحر المتوسط
وتعزيز قواعدها ووجودها العسكريه هناك كما
وضع البعض تحركها العسكريه في سوريا في
سياق تحدي ما تصفها بالهيمنه الغربيه على
العالم فكان ان تحدته في اوكرانيا فسوريا
التي كشف خبراء عن مشروعات هناك تهدد
هيمنتها على تصدير الغاز للقاره الاوروبيه
ذاك كلام المحللين فالروس الذين يقرون بان
القوه العسكريه اصبحت الاداه الرئيسيه في
حل المشكلات الدوليه لطالما سووا لتدخلهم
في سوريا بمحاربه من يصفونهم
بالارهابيين لكنهم يضيفون الى الاهداف
الان ما بدا اخما لثورات العرب ثورات
خبرتها موسكو في افنيت الخلفيه وتخشى من
عدواها اشد الخشيه فلعلها ارتدت حتى الى
داخل روسيا هكذا وجدت موسكو مشروعات حلفاء
في بعض المنقلبين على الثورات كما حدث في
مصر بزعم انهم يمثلون ارادات شعوبهم كما
دفعتها منافع شتى لربط صلات مع اخرين في
ليبيا معجبين كما يبدو بالتجربه المصريه
وكبدا ثمه حديث عن مساع روسيه لرفع حظر
التسليح عن قوات اللواء الليبي المتقاعد
خليفه حفتر وهو ما فهم استفزازا لا
لليبيين فحسب وانما ايضا لحلفاء واشنطن
الاقليميين
اهو الانتقام اذا من خديعه الحاله الليبيه
حين فوجئ الروس بتغيير شعبي لم يبقي على
حليفهم هناك وراوا يدا غربيه وراء ذلك
ردوا على
العملاء اذا كان الامر هكذا فليست الادوار
الروسيه مجرد محاوله لاعاده ترتيب الاوراق
في منطقتنا فحسب لمرام سياسيه
واقتصاديه فمسك تنشد هدفا استراتيجيا اشمل
نظاما عالميا جديدا تصفه بالاكثر
عدلا ما يسميه وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي
لافروف نظام ما بعد الغرب تتهم بلاده ذلك
الغرب بقياده واشنطن بمحاوله اعاقه تشكيله
ما يشجع برايه على الفوضه وفي نظر الروس
فان ثورات الشعوب جميعها جزء من تلك
الفوضه نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه من موسكو
لينا سوبونينا المستشاره في المعهد الدولي
لدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن باريس صلاح
القادري المحاضر في المعهد الاوروبي
للعلوم الانسانيه نبدا بموسكو سيده
سوبونينا ما الذي
اخاف موسكو من هذه الثورات الملونه في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا كما سماها
شويجو روسيا لا تخاف من شيء ومثل ما قال
وزير الدفاع الروسي في هذه الايام
الترسانه العسكريه بما فيها الترسانه
النوويه الروسيه هي في حاله التهب الدائم
وروسيا تستطيع ان تدافع عن نفسها
ولكن من يعرف تاريخ روسيا فيعرف بشكل جيده
انه بلادنا عاشت ايام الحرب الاهليه وعاشت
مرحله الثورات المتتاليه خاصه في مرحله
اي
القيصر في من سنه 1905 لسنه
فهذه الخبره كانت سيئه جدا بالنسبه لروسيا
مثل ما استنتج من ذلك الفيلسوف الروسي
المشهور برداي
انه روسيا هي عاشت مرحله الثورات ولكنه
قال بانه الاصلاح التدريجي
واحسن شيء للشعب روسيا واحسن من اي ثوره
لانه الثوره دائما تكون مؤلمه نعم هذا ال
موضوع الاصلاح التدريجي
يعني لو اخذنا بالضبط ما قاله شويجو سيد
صلاح القادري اعتبر ان موجه هنا انا اقتبس
موجه الثورات الملونه احدث احدثت
التغييرات خطيره في السياسات الدوليه
واخلت بتوازن القوى في مختلف مناطق العالم
وذكر يوغسلافيا جورجيا العراق ليبيا
اوكرانيا سوريا مع ان هذا الاصلاح
التدريجي كان يمكن ان يكون متاح من خلال
هذه الثورات على سبيل المثال في في العراق
او او او في
غيرها اظن ان المتحدث باسم الوزير وزير
الدفاع الروسي كان يتكلم عن شيء عالق في
الذاكره الجمعيه الروسيه وهو الذي تعرضت
الهزيمه النكراء التي تعرضت لها القوات
الروسيه في افغانستان حيث كان هناك ثوره
من نوع ما ضد حاكم افغانستان في ذلك
الزمان
ووجود مقاتلين عرب في ذلك تلك المرحله وال
الحاقهم هزيمه بالقوات الروسيه ودحرهم
منها بالاضافه الى مشاركه هؤلاء ما نسميهم
بين قوسين المجاهدين العرب والتحاقهم
بالثوره الشيشانيه الاولى والثوره
الشيشانيه الثانيه وكذلك في جمهوريه
داغستان هؤلاء شكلوا ثوره كالوا شكلوا
ماذا خزانا قويا مثل ضربه قويه للقوات
الروسيه في جمهوريه داغستان وفي جمهوريه
الشيشان ف لذلك كانت ال كانت ال روسيا
سباقه في في تبني سياسه عدائيه كبيره تجاه
هذه الثورات وخصوصا انها استفادت من
تاخرها في التحرك في في في في ملف الثوره
الليبيه حيث
ان تاخرها في التحرك فتح المجال للقوه
الغربيه وكذلك للقوى الشعبيه التي ارت ضد
نظام القذافي حتى انها لم تستطع ان تستدرك
الامر ف استفادت من هذا الدرس و وتحركت
بشكل مغاير في ال في في القضيه السوريه
وكانت منذ البدايه واقفه مع النظام نظام
بشار ولذلك هي دعمته عسكريا وسياسيا وكذلك
دبلوماسيا بل كانت قواتها مشاركه في
المجازر التي تعرض لها الشعب السوري هذا
من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه يجب ان لا ننسى ان
سياسه سوريا روسيا الحاليه في الشرق
الاوسط وفي شمال افريقيا ليست خاضعه لمنطق
الثورات فقط بل هي خاضعه كذلك
لاحدى العناصر او المحاور الاساسيه
للسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه الجديده مع وصول
فلاديمير بوتين الى رئاسه روسيا والتي هي
تق على على على احد احد هذه المحاور
المحور الاول وهو تامين ممرات الغاز الذي
هو يمثل الشريان الاساسي لاقتصاد الروسي
وكذلك الامر الثاني هو بناء قواعد عسكريه
والسيطره على البحر الاسود شمالا وعلى
المياه الدافئه والتي اقصد بها البحر
الابيض المتوسط نعم ولكن ولكن اللافت
اللافت اسمح لي
اللافت ان السيد شويجو سيده سوبونينا لم
يشر الى تونس او مصر ضمن هذه
الثورات الملونه وهذا
اغفال لابد ان يكون له معنى لان النموذج
التونسي او نموذج الاطاحه بمبارك في مصر
كان فعلا ثوره سلميه شعبيه واسعه تعتقد ان
هذا الاغفال لم يكن هكذا
عفويا هو كان من باب فقط السؤال بعد بعد
اذنك سيد قادري السؤال للسيده سبون تفضلي
سيده
سبون
لا هدف سيد شويجو لم يكن الدخول في في
تاريخ الحديث للعالم العربي ولم يذكر هذه
البلدان ليس مقصودا
برايه وموقف روسيا تجاه كل الثورات والان
موقف متحفظ جدا ون نتائج الربيع العربي هي
نتائج غير ايجابيه باستثناء تونس ممكن نعم
ولكن حتى تونس ومصر لديها مشاكلها داخليه
متعلقه بالوضع الاقتصادي
وهذا يثير لحتى الان بعض التساؤلات
ف كثيرون الان يسمون الربيع العربي الشتاء
عربيا او
خريفا عربيا
و هذا ما كانت تقوله روسيا منذ بدايه هذه
ولكن سيده سوبونينا هناك هناك هناك مساله
بعد اذنك هناك مساله هناك مساله مهمه سيده
سوبونينا ذكرها وزير الدفاع الروسي وهي
تعتبر غير دقيقه ان لم نقل خاطئه تماما هو
اشار الى ان استخدام القوه العسكريه كان
جزءا من تلك الثورات الملونه في حين ان لا
ت تونس استعمل السلاح ولا مصر استعمل
السلاح وفي اغلب الاحيان سواء في ليبيا او
في سوريا استعمال السلاح كان في مرحله
لاحقه بعد ان استعمل نظام السلاح اذا
اللجوء الى الى القوه لم يكن جزء من تلك
الثورات كما اوحى بذلك
شويجو انا اعرف ما كان يقصد به السيد
شويجو وقت كان يتكلم حول استخدام القوه من
الخارج
لانه بالعاده نحن في روسيا
نضرب بمثالين اولا هي حرب العراق في سنه
2003 ولا شك
انها كانت تدخلا امريكيا اجنبيا وهذا
التدخل لم يؤدي الى ازدهار الديمقراطيه في
العراق ابدا
وبعض المحللين في روسيا يعتقد دون انه
التغيير الشامل في منطقه الشرق الاوسط هو
بدا ليس في سنه 2011 اما بدا في سنه
فاما المثال الثاني هو ما ذكرتموه هو
احداث ليبيا في سنه
نعم هي استخدام القوه من قبل حلف ناتو
هو بدا فيما بعد ولكن ايضا نتائج هذا
التدخل اللي هي كانت محزنه واهم من ذلك
المشكله بانه دول الغرب هي لا تتحمل
المسؤوليه فيما بعد على ما يحدث في هذه
البلدان هذه هي مشكله ولحتى الان علماء
العالم لم يجيبوا على هذه الاسئله لانه
كانت هناك دراسات انا اعرف حتى في الامم
المتحده في حلف ناتو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
انه التدخل طيب وماذا بعد من يتحمل للكن
هناك هناك مساله ايضا مهمه سيده سوبونينا
هناك ايضا مساله هناك ايضا مساله مهمه
اريد ان اسال عنها السيد صالح صالح
القادري واقفلها وزير الدفاع الروسي
بالكامل ان هذه الثورات اندلعت نتيجه
ممارسات ونتيجه الديكتاتوريات ونتيجه
تراكم للاخطاء ولقم هو لم يشر تقريبا الى
ذلك هل هل تعتقد بان هذا الاغفال له معنى
سيد
قادري الاغفال كان مقصودا لان سياسه روسيا
في الخارجيه في العالم العربي هي جزء من
سياسه الغربيه في العالم العربي والتي هي
مبنيه على على دعم الانظمه الدكتاتوريه
والانظمه اللا ديمقراطيه المهم عندها هي
تحصيل مصالحها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والجيو استراتيجيه في هذه المناطق ولكن
فقط لو سمحت لتعليق على على ما اعتبره على
الاقل كمواطن عربي النكته الذي قالها
الزميل من ال المتدخل الكريم من روسيا
حينما تقال قال ان امريكا حينما تدخلت في
العراق سنه 2003 لم تاتي بازدهار
للديمقراطيه فهل يتكرم علينا الضيف ليبين
لنا كيفه ازدهرت الديمقراطيه في سوريا
بالتدخل الروسي وال والمجازر التي ارتكبها
الطيران الروسي في حلب وفي درعا وفي كل
المدن السوريه الامر الذي كان واضحا في
هذا والرساله الواضحه التي كان يريد ان ان
يبثها او ان لنها وزير الدفاع الروسي في
هذا التصريح هو ان السياسه الخارجيه
الروسيه هي تعتمد اساسا على الثوره
المضاده وتغذيه الثوره المضاده وحرمان هذه
الشعوب العربيه من الثوره على هذه الانظمه
الفاسده وهذه الانظمه الاستبداديه فحت
الكلام ربما اكث ربما التدخل الروسي يعني
التدخل الروسي في سوريا الذي اشرت اليه
ربما هو الاكثر اثاره للجدل في الفتره
الماضيه ولهذا هذا نريد ان نعرف بعد
الفاصل طبيعه الاهداف الجيوسياسيه التي
سعت موسكو الى تحقيقها بناء على تدخلها
ونتائج تدخلها في سوريا لنا
[موسيقى]
عوده
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد تصريحات
وزير الدفاع الروسي عن تمكن بلاده بتدخلها
في سوريا من قطع ما سماه سلسله الثورات
الملونه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
سيده سوبونينا
كاه جي
سياسيه تعتقدين بان روسيا حققت ما اراده ب
ما ارادته بتدخلها في
سوريا اولا بالنسبه لاهداف روسيا في سوريا
روسيا اتت الى سوريا بطلب من قبل حكومه
سوريا
وبذا السبب حسب المعايير الدوليه التدخل
العسكري الروسي في هذ البلاد هو تدخل
المروع يعني هذا يعني هذا من الناحيه هذا
من الناحيه الشكليه هذا من الناحيه
الشكليه سيده هذا من الناحيه الشكليه سيده
سبونه موسكو عندما ارادت التدخل عندما
ارادت التدخل تدخلت يعني لو لو لم يطلب
بشار الاسد او طلبه من الناحيه الموضوعيه
هذا ما كانت تريده روسيا بالطبع
يعني الناحيه الشكليه هي مهمه جدا خاصه
الان ونحن نعيش في مرحله العالم المتغير
دور الامم المتحده يثير التساؤلات وكل من
بلدان العالم
الان يواجه الصراع على مكانها في المستقبل
على الرصيد الدولي فروسيا تعتقد بانه هذه
الشكليات هي مهمه جدا و هذا خلافا مع
امريكا في سنه 2003 وايضا اهداف روسيه في
سوريا كانت
مختلفه الذ حققته الان عمليه عمليه موسكو
بتدخلها في في روسيا ما الذي حققته نعم س
سجاب على هذا السؤال ولكن ضيفكم الكريم قد
قارن سياسه روسيا في سوريا مع شعارات
امريكان في العراق حول ازدهار الديمقراطيه
ولكن روسيا لم
تطرح هذا الشيء في سوريا روسيا كانت واضحه
جدا وقالت انها اتت الى هناك بموضوع وبخطط
مكافحه الارهاب روسيا تعتقد انها حافظت
على الوله سوريه كدوله
موحده روسيا تعتقد
انها ساعدت حكومه سوريا بلا شك نحن لا
نخفي هذا الشيء والان روسيا بحاجه للعمليه
السياسيه في سوريا انه روسيا لا تريد
الازمه في سوريا ان تستمر وهذا ايضا خلاف
مع امريكان والذين بعيدين عن هذه المنطقه
ويمكن عنده
مصحه هذه الاز لانه يردون اضعاف العرب
يعني ك مصالح استراتيجيه وزير الدفاع قال
نحن منعنا من وصول الارهابيين الى بلادنا
هذا جانب ولكن هناك جانب اخر موسكو ابرمت
اتفاقات عسكريه طويله الامد مع النظام في
في سوريا هذا جزء من من الاهداف التي كانت
لموسكو
بتقديرك روسيا تريد ان تكون لها قاعدتان
عسكريتان في حميم وطرطوس في طرطوس الان
لحتى الان نقطه الارتكاز اذا استعملنا
المصطلح العسكري يعني هي لحتى الان لم
تتحول الى القاعده البحريه الحقيقيه روسيا
حتعمل على موضوع توسيع
ا نقطه الارتكاز في طرطوس وتحويلها الى
القاعده نعم روسيا بحاجه لهذا الشيء
وروسيا حققت هذا الهدف ولكن مصلحه روسيا
هو انهاء الازمه في سوريا روسيا لا تريد
هذه الازمه ان تستمر فبهذا السبب وزير
شوجو ايضا تكلم حول عمليه استنه السياسيه
وبهذا السبب هو قال اكثر من مره في
بتصريحاته الاخيره بانه مصلحه روسيا هي
انهاء الازمه انهاء الحرب في سوريا ولكن
ربما انهاء الحرب في سوريا ربما انهاء
الحرب في سوريا سيده سوبونينا بعد ان تكون
اتضحت الصوره لروسيا عن الاهداف الكبرى
الاستراتيجيه التي حققتها هل تعتقد سيد
صلاح القادري بان موسكو افلحت في تحقيق ما
ارادته في في
سوريا نعم نعم السياسه الخارجيه عموما في
الشرق الاوسط لروسيا قائمه على ثلاثه
اهداف استراتيجيه واهداف جيو استراتيجيه
الهدف الاستراتيجي الاول هو تثبيت الحلفاء
القدماء وكان على راسهم النظام الروسي
وكذلك النظام القذافي الذي سقط و محاوله
اعا اعاده احيائه مع خليفه حفطر واسترجاع
كذلك النظام المصري وعلى ادل على ذلك من
استرجاع للنظام المصري هو العقود التي
ابرمها النظام المصري مع روسيا اخيرا
وكذلك موقفه في مجلس الامم المتح في الامم
المتحده اخيرا التي كان ضد النظام السعودي
وكان شيئا مفاجئا للجميع هذا من الجهه
الاولى هي تثبيط الحلفاء القدم والقدماء و
وصناعه حلفاء جدد في الشرق الاوسط الامر
الثاني هو صناعه قواعد عسكريه تسمح له
بالسيطره على المياه الدافئه في البحر
الابيض المتوسط عن طريق القاعده في حمحيم
في في في سوريا وكذلك الميناء البحري في
طرطوس كذلك في سوريا والقاعده المحتمله في
سنه 2019 في مرسى مطرو بالاسكندريه في في
مصر وكذلك القاعده المحتمله في بنغازي
والتي تكلم عليها تفاوضت عليها روسيا
اخيرا مع الخليفه حفتر الهدف الاستراتيجي
الثالث لروسيا في منطقه شرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا هو تاميم الممرات الغاز وخصوصا
بعد ان بعد ان عن بعد ان انتهى الاتفاق
الذي عقدته مع اوكرانيا من اجل توريد
الغاز الى اوروبا وسيطرتها على قاعده
سباستبول
بجزر القرم فهي الان تحاول عن طريق تركيا
وعن طريق تركيا في مشروع السيل السيل
البحري الذي هو يؤمم لتركيا 25% من
حاجياتها وكذلك تصدير 45 مليار متر مكعب
الى اوروبا وك اذا في ضو هذا في ضو هذا
سيد ضوء هذا سيد القادري يعني في نهايه
البرنامج تعتقد ان موسكو في النهايه نجحت
بشكل رئيسي في هذه الاهداف التي اشرت
اليها الان
جميعا
نجحت الى جزء كبير ولكنه كان على حساب
ارواح عشرات الالاف ومئات الالاف وكذلك
تطلعات وطموحات الشعب الشعوب العربيه هذا
الذي حصل بالضبط ولا ادل على ذلك من جرائم
التي ارتكبتها ضد الانسانيه في سوريا
وخصوصا وكذلك دعمها دعمها للانظمه
الدكتاتوريه في مصر والخليفه وال الخليفه
والجنرال حفطر في المشهد الليبي باختصار
سيده سبونه تعتقدين بان موسكو واعيه انها
نجحت كما
ترى روسيا تفهم انها نجحت في المرحله
الانتقاليه هذه
والاسباب الرئيسيه لا تتعلق فقط بممرات
الغاز هناك مواضيع اهم من ذلك وهو انه
العالم هذا هو يتغير ف
روسيا الان حافظت على مكانها في على رصيد
الولي وهذا اهم من غاز والنفط واسعار
الوقود ولكن روسيا تفهم بانه النجاح
الحقيقي حياتي عندما ستنتهي الحرب في
سوريا وهذا ممكن ان يحدث فقط لو كانت هناك
شراكه حقيقيه ما بين روسيا والاخرين روسيا
تسعى لهذا النوع من التعاون ولكننا للاسف
لا نشعر بانه امريكا على سبيل المثال
تستجيب لهذا الشيء بشكل حقيقي شكرا لك
سيده لينا سوبونينا المستشاره في المعهد
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه شكرا ايضا
لضيفنا من باريس صلاح القادري المحاضر في
المعهد الاوروبي للعلوم الانسانيه بهذا
نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله l